Je travaille avec une espèce appelée bonobo.
Et je suis heureuse la plupart du temps,
parce que je pense que c'est l'espèce la plus heureuse de cette planète.
C'est en quelque sorte un secret bien gardé.
Cette espèce vit uniquement au Congo.
Et on les voit dans peu de zoos, à cause de leur comportement sexuel.
Leur comportement sexuel ressemble trop à celui des humains,
ce qui met mal à l'aise la plupart d'entre nous.
(Rires)
Mais...
en réalité, ils ont beaucoup à nous apprendre, car ils ont
une société très égalitaire et très empathique.
Et le comportement sexuel n'est pas confiné à un seul aspect de leur vie
qu'ils mettraient en quelque sorte de côté.
Il imprègne l'ensemble de leur vie.
Et il est utilisé pour la communication.
Et il est utilisé pour la résolution de conflits.
Et je crois que peut-être à un moment donné dans notre Histoire,
nous avons en quelque sorte fragmenté nos vies.
Nous avons divisé notre monde en plein de catégories.
Et donc, en gros, tout a une case dans laquelle il faut que ça rentre.
Mais je ne crois pas que nous étions comme ça à l'origine.
Beaucoup de gens pensent que le monde animal est mécanique
et que l'homme a quelque chose de tout à fait spécial.
Peut-être que c'est sa capacité à avoir une pensée causale.
Peut-être que c'est quelque chose de spécial dans son cerveau
qui lui permet d'avoir le langage.
qui lui permet de fabriquer des outils et d'avoir les mathématiques.
Bon, je ne sais pas. On a découvert des Tasmaniens
au 17ème siècle qui n'avaient pas le feu.
Ils n'avaient pas d'outils en pierre.
À notre connaissance ils n'avaient pas de musique.
Donc quand on les compare avec les bonobos,
le bonobo est un peu plus poilu.
Il ne se tient pas tout-à-fait aussi droit.
Mais il y a beaucoup de similarités.
Et je crois que lorsqu'on considère la culture,
on commence petit à petit à comprendre
comment on est arrivé là où nous en sommes.
Et je ne pense pas vraiment que ce soit dans notre biologie,
Je pense que nous l'avons attribué à notre biologie,
mais je ne pense pas vraiment que ça se trouve là.
Donc maintenant je vais vous présenter
à cette espèce appelée bonobo.
Voici Kanzi.
C'est un bonobo.
En ce moment, il est dans une forêt de Géorgie.
Sa mère venait à l'origine d'une forêt d'Afrique.
Et nous l'avons accueillie alors qu'elle n'était qu'une... juste à la puberté,
quand elle avait six ou sept ans.
Là vous voyez un bonobo sur votre droite,
et un chimpanzé sur votre gauche.
Manifestement, le chimpanzé a un peu plus de mal à marcher.
Le bonobo, même s'il reste plus petit que nous, avec des bras toutefois plus longs,
se tient plus droit, tout comme nous.
Voici le bonobo en comparaison d'un australopithèque comme Lucy.
Comme vous pouvez le voir il n'y a pas beaucoup de différence,
entre la façon de marcher d'un bonobo
et la façon dont l'un des premiers australopithèques aurait marché.
Quand ils se tournent vers nous vous pouvez voir
que la zone pelvienne des premiers australopithèques est un peu plus plate
et n'a pas besoin de tourner autant d'un côté à l'autre.
Donc la... la marche bipède est un peu plus facile.
Et maintenant on voit les quatre.
[Vidéo] Le bonobo sauvage vit en Afrique centrale, dans la jungle
encerclée par le fleuve Congo.
Des arbres de 40 mètres de haut, 130 pieds,
peuplent densément la zone.
C'est un scientifique japonais
qui le premier a entrepris des études sur terrain sérieuses sur le bonobo,
il y a quasiment trente ans.
Les bonobos sont légèrement plus petits que les chimpanzés.
Avec un corps fin, les bonobos sont par nature des créatures très douces.
De longues et minutieuses études ont apporté de nombreuses découvertes à leur sujet.
L'une des découvertes fut que les bonobos sauvages marchent souvent sur deux pattes.
Qui plus est, ils sont capables de marcher en se tenant droit sur de longues distances.
Allons d'abord dire bonjour à Austin, et nous irons ensuite à la structure A.
[Susan Savage-Rambaugh] Ça c'est Kanzi et moi, dans la forêt.
Rien de ce que vous allez voir dans cette vidéo-ci n'a été répété.
Ce ne sont pas des astuces.
Il se trouve qu'elles ont été saisies sur la pellicule spontanément,
par la chaîne japonaise NHK.
Nous avons huit bonobos.
[Vidéo] Regarde tout ce qu'il y a pour notre feu de camp.
[SS] Une famille entière dans notre centre de recherches.
[Vidéo] Tu nous aides à ramasser quelques branches ?
Bien.
Il nous faut encore plus de branches.
J'ai un briquet dans ma poche si tu en as besoin.
C'est un nid de guêpes.
Tu peux le sortir.
J'espère que j'ai un briquet.
Tu peux utiliser le briquet pour démarrer le feu.
[SS] Kanzi est très intéressé par le feu.
Il n'en fait pas encore, sans briquet,
mais je pense que s'il voyait quelqu'un en faire, il serait peut-être capable de...
de faire un feu sans briquet.
Il apprend comment entretenir un feu.
Il apprend les usages du feu,
simplement en observant ce que nous nous faisons avec le feu.
(Rires)
Voici un sourire sur un visage de bonobo.
Ça ce sont des bruits de joie.
[Vidéo] Tu es content.
Tu es très content de cette partie.
Tu dois mettre un peu d'eau sur le feu. Tu vois l'eau ?
Bien joué.
[SS] Il a oublié de fermer la fermeture éclair de l'arrière de son sac à dos.
Mais il aime porter des choses d'un endroit à un autre.
[Vidéo] Austin, je t'entends dire Austin.
[SS] Il parle à d'autres bonobos du labo, à longue distance,
plus loin que ce qu'on peut entendre.
Voici sa soeur.
C'est la première fois qu'elle essaye de conduire une voiturette de golf.
[Vidéo] Au revoir.
(Rires)
[SS] Elle atteint les pédales en bas, mais pas le volant.
Elle passe de la marche arrière à la marche avant
et elle s'accroche au volant, plus qu'elle ne le tourne.
(Rires)
Comme nous, elle sait que cet individu dans le miroir, c'est elle.
(Musique)
[Vidéo] En élevant des bonobos dans une culture à la fois bonobo et humaine,
et en recueillant des informations sur leur développement pendant deux décennies,
des scientifiques examinent comment des forces culturelles
(Rires)
ont pu avoir un impact durant l'évolution humaine.
Son nom est Nyota.
Cela veut dire étoile en swahili.
(Musique)
Panbanisha essaye de couper les cheveux de Nyota, avec une paire de ciseaux.
Dans la nature, on sait que le parent bonobo fait la toilette de sa progéniture.
Ici Panbanisha utilise des ciseaux à la place de ses mains,
pour toiletter Nyota.
Très impressionnant.
Des manœuvres précises des mains sont nécessaires
pour accomplir des tâches délicates comme celle-ci.
Nyota essaye d'imiter Panbanisha en utilisant lui-même les ciseaux.
Quand elle se rend compte que Nyota pourrait se blesser,
Panbanisha, comme n'importe quelle mère humaine,
tire doucement sur les ciseaux pour les récupérer.
Il sait maintenant découper un cuir animal épais.
[SS] Kanzi a appris à fabriquer des outils en pierre.
[Vidéo] Kanzi fabrique maintenant ses outils,
tout comme nos ancêtres les ont peut-être fabriqués,
il y a 2,5 millions d'années...
en tenant les pierres dans les deux mains, pour frapper l'une contre l'autre.
Il a appris qu'en utilisant ses deux mains
et en frappant des coups obliques,
il peut faire des éclats beaucoup plus grands et plus tranchants.
Kanzi choisit un éclat qu'il pense être assez tranchant.
Le cuir épais est difficile à couper, même avec un couteau.
La pierre que Kanzi utilise est extrêmement dure
et idéale pour la fabrication d'outils en pierre, mais difficile à manipuler,
car elle requiert une grande dextérité.
La pierre de Kanzi vient de Gona, en Éthiopie
et elle est identique à celles qu'utilisaient nos ancêtres africains
il y a 2,5 millions d'années.
Voici les pierres que Kanzi a utilisées
et voici les éclats qu'il a fabriqués.
Les côtés aplatis et tranchants sont comme des lames de couteaux.
Si on les compare aux outils utilisés par nos ancêtres,
on remarque une ressemblance frappante avec ceux de Kanzi.
Panbanisha a très envie d'aller se promener dans les bois.
Elle n'arrête pas de regarder par la fenêtre.
[SS] C'est... laissez-moi vous montrer quelque chose qu'on ne pensait pas qu'ils feraient.
Vidéo: Depuis plusieurs jours maintenant, Panbanisha n'est pas sortie.
[SS] Normalement, je parle du langage.
[Vidéo] Puis Panbanisha fait quelque chose d'inattendu.
[SS] Mais comme on m'a conseillé de ne pas faire ce que je fais normalement,
je ne vous ai pas dit que ces singes possédaient le langage.
C'est un langage géométrique.
[Vidéo] Elle saisit un morceau de craie
et commence à écrire quelque chose sur le sol.
Qu'écrit-elle ?
[SS] Elle dit aussi le nom de la chose, avec sa voix.
[Vidéo] Maintenant elle va voir le Dr Sue et commence à écrire à nouveau.
[SS] Ce sont ses symboles sur son clavier.
(Musique)
Ils émettent un son quand elle les touche.
[Vidéo] Panbanisha communique au Dr Sue l'endroit où elle veut aller.
La structure A représente une hutte dans les bois.
Comparez l'écriture à la craie avec le lexigramme du clavier.
Panbanisha a commencé par écrire les lexigrammes dans le sol de la forêt.
Très bien. Magnifique, Panbanisha.
[SS] Au début nous n'avons pas vraiment réalisé ce qu'elle faisait,
jusqu'à ce qu'on recule, qu'on regarde et qu'on tourne le dessin.
[Vidéo] Ce lexigramme fait également allusion à un endroit en forêt.
La ligne courbe ressemble beaucoup au lexigramme.
Le symbole suivant dessiné par Panbanisha représente un collier.
Il indique le collier que Panbanisha doit porter lorsqu'elle sort.
[SS] C'est une exigence institutionnelle.
[Vidéo] Ce symbole n'est pas aussi clair que les autres,
Mais on peut voir que Panbanisha essaye de reproduire une ligne courbe
et plusieurs lignes droites.
Les chercheurs ont commencé à enregistrer ce que disait Panbanisha,
en écrivant les lexigrammes sur le sol à la craie.
Panbanisha regardait.
Bientôt, elle aussi a commencé à écrire.
Les talents des bonobos ont stupéfié les scientifiques à travers le monde.
Comment se sont-ils développés ?
[SS] Nous avons découvert que la chose la plus importante
pour permettre aux bonobos d'acquérir le langage, ce n'est pas de leur apprendre.
C'est simplement d'utiliser le langage en leur présence,
parce que la force motrice dans l'acquisition d'un langage
c'est de comprendre ce que d'autres personnes, qui sont importantes pour vous, vous disent.
Une fois que vous avez cette aptitude,
la capacité de produire du langage
vient assez naturellement et assez librement.
Donc nous voulons créer un environnement dans lequel les bonobos
aiment tous les individus avec lesquels ils interagissent.
Nous voulons créer un environnement dans lequel ils s'amusent,
et un environnement dans lequel les autres
sont des individus importants pour eux.
Cet environnement fait ressortir un potentiel inattendu
chez Kanzi et Panbanisha.
Panbanisha s'amuse à jouer de l'harmonica,
jusqu'à ce que Nyota, qui a maintenant un an, le vole.
Puis il regarde avidement dans la bouche de sa mère.
Est-ce qu'il cherche d'où venait le son ?
Le Dr Sue pense qu'il est essentiel de laisser prospérer une telle curiosité.
Cette fois Panbanisha joue du piano électrique.
On ne l'a pas forcée à apprendre le piano,
elle a vu un chercheur en jouer et s'y est intéressée.
Vas-y. Vas-y. J'écoute.
Joue la partie très rapide que tu as jouée. Voilà, cette partie.
Kanzi joue du xylophone,
utilisant ses deux mains, il accompagne avec enthousiasme le Dr Sue qui chante.
Kanzi et Panbanisha
sont stimulés par cet environnement plein d'amusements,
qui encourage l'émergence de ces aptitudes culturelles.
(Rires)
OK, maintenant attrape les monstres. Attrape-les.
Prends aussi les cerises.
Là fais attention, éloigne-toi d'eux maintenant.
Là tu peux les chasser à nouveau. C'est le moment de les chasser.
Maintenant tu dois t'éloigner. Va-t-en.
Enfuis-toi. Enfuis-toi.
Là on peut les chasser à nouveau. Va les attraper.
Oh non !
C'est bien Kanzi. Très bien. Merci beaucoup.
Aucun d'entre nous, bonobo ou humain, ne peut même imaginer ?
[SS] Donc nous avons un environnement bi-espèce, nous appelons ça une panhomoculture.
Nous apprenons à devenir comme eux.
Nous apprenons à communiquer avec eux,
dans des tons très aigus.
Nous sommes en train d'apprendre qu'ils ont probablement un langage dans la nature.
Et ils apprennent à devenir comme nous.
Parce que nous croyons que ce n'est pas de la biologie, c'est de la culture.
Donc nous partageons des outils, de la technologie et du langage
avec une autre espèce.
Merci.